welcome back to Long crime daily
everybody a tech executive behind huge
companies like cash app and square was
murdered on the Streets of San Francisco
this week and so far police have not
released any information about a suspect
or motive babli was found with stab
wounds around 2 30 a.m on Tuesday and
died at a hospital local media reports
that Lee managed to call 9-1-1 on his
cell phone saying that he'd been stabbed
and needed help and surveillance video
shows him walking up to a parked car
that had its hazard lights on he lifted
his shirt presumably to show the person
inside that he was injured but the car
drove away he managed to walk another
few feet before ultimately collapsing
Lee created the payment service cash app
while he was working with another
payment company Square he was also
involved in cryptocurrency firms like
mobile coin Lee's family says the father
of two moved to Miami Last fall he was
back in San Francisco for a Leadership
Summit and to meet up with a few friends
Terry really said case here you know the
report said that at least one person
drove away the decline to help Lee I'm
thinking that person could be liable in
some way am I right well actually in
California no he is not liable for
driving away there is a law in
California It's a Good Samaritan law but
basically under the law you have the
right to drive away and do absolutely
nothing you cannot be charged criminally
you cannot be charged civilly and if you
do stop and help because what they want
to do is to promote the fact that you
should help people if they are in need
of emergency aid then you also cannot be
held civilly liable if in fact you're
not doing it to get money so if a doctor
stops and there's some negligence then
you could be sued but if you're doing it
in good faith you're not expecting any
money and you're not willfully trying to
hurt the person then you're not going to
be held liable either Brian the San
Francisco police chief is 100 confident
that they're going to find the suspect
you think they should be well you
suggest that I would say you shouldn't
be 100 confident in anything but
according to their own statistics
there's an 80 to 85 10 clearance rate
for homicides that's high just generally
but also High when you look at other
clearance rates of other departments the
other reason why I think this case
specifically may be more solvable than
others is the very fact that there's
around so many Office Buildings I think
they would be able to piece together a
number of surveillance videos to get at
least the make and model of the vehicle
kind of think of the how they got Brian
Coburg or through tracking his vehicle
and I think it's a matter of time until
they find out who the suspect is in this
case well I hope they're right you know
because this is really a case that needs
answers now when you hear this case it
might actually remind you of a different
murder that happened on the opposite
Coast a young woman was murdered in
Queens New York in the 1960s and she's
remembered as the victim who died as her
neighbors watched and did nothing but
that's not actually the whole story in
1964 Kitty Genovese was a 28 year old
bartender according to historical
accounts and trial testimony she was
walking from a parking lot to her
apartment late at night when a man
chased her and stabbed her twice in the
back a neighbor leaned out his window
and shouted at the suspect and
eventually ran off but that suspect came
back about 10 minutes later attacking
Genovese again behind the building out
of the sight of the apartment windows at
least two people reported that they
called police and an elderly woman even
stayed with the dying victim until help
got there now despite this about two
weeks after the killing a New York Times
headline read 37 who saw murder didn't
call police police later questioned
Winston Mosley about the attack and he
admitted to killing and raping Genovese
along with at least two other women he
went to prison and died there in 2016.
now from that New York Times story came
the idea of the bystander effect
psychologists theorized that no one
helped because they all assumed someone
else would the case became a very
popular part of social psychology
textbooks for decades afterwards in both
the United States and the UK until it
was debunked
[Music]
we've got a brand new case starting up
next week in Columbus Ohio that we want
to talk to you about a former vice squad
police detective is standing trial for a
second time in the murder of a sex
worker while allegedly undercover in
2018 investigators say defendant Andrew
Mitchell picked up the victim
23-year-old Donna Castleberry in an
unmarked squad car Mitchell then tried
to arrest Castleberry who engaged in sex
work in the area audio recordings
reportedly show that Castleberry didn't
believe that Mitchell was a police
officer he was reportedly dressed in
plain clothing and didn't have his badge
or police radio on him which actually
violates Department policy investigators
say that there was a scuffle inside the
car and Castleberry slashed the
defendant's hand with a knife that is
when police say Mitchell shot
Castleberry three times and she was
later pronounced dead at the hospital
Mitchell was initially tried last year
and he said on the stand that he acted
in self-defense that trial ended in a
hung jury and ultimately a mistrial
Mitchell is also charged federally with
arresting sex workers and then forcing
them to engage in sex acts in exchange
for their freedom and the death of
Castleberry Mitchell faces up to life in
prison if convicted jury selection
scheduled to start on Monday so Terry
the defendant being charged with murder
and voluntary manslaughter what's the
difference between the two charges here
well first of all I've just got to say
what a horrible case this is but murder
in Ohio is different than voluntary
manslaughter but they both have that
requirement for that element of intent
meaning that they intended to kill
someone but with voluntary manslaughter
what you have is sort of a situation
where there's this excited aggravated
rage and you just sort of make this act
Without Really Trying to do it in any
premeditated way here I don't think that
they're going to be able to show or I
hope they don't show that it is
manslaughter because this seemed to me
need to be a premeditated murder he
intended to kill her he put her in that
back seat why was she even in the car
and frankly these other charges against
him to me all add up to the highest
crime that he could possibly be
committed of and that would be murder so
of both of those choices hopefully the
prosecution is going to be able to show
that he really intended to take a route
because he was upset that she attacked
him well Brian unless I'm missing
something it's likely going to be the
same Witnesses presenting the same
evidence why would there be a different
difference this time around I think the
defense has the advantage in the first
case of the element of surprise they can
spring upon the prosecution arguments
that they might not have thought about I
think this time the prosecution's got to
refocus the case and make the argument
that you cannot claim self-defense if
you're doing something illegal let me
answer some of Terry's questions this
man was a John he's a person who
purchases sex from sex workers because
if you're arresting someone you don't
arrest him in the back of a car you
arrest him outside of the car you check
them for weapons they're handcuffed you
place them in the back seat you go in
the front seat and you drop them to the
precinct there's no reason for the
officer to be in the backseat with this
person when they're not handcuffed he
was there for a reason and he shot her
he was doing something illegal not
self-defense all right Brian Terry thank
you both so much everyone out there
thanks for joining us here on Long crime
daily we're going to see you next time
as we discuss Justice in America
[Music]
foreign